la 5e chaîne continue également
d'alimenter le débat politique Jacques
Lang le ministre de la Culture qui
s'exprimait ce matin au Forum de RMC a
avoué publiquement l'inquiétude que lui
inspire cette chaîne il craint pour
l'avenir de la création française Jérôme
sdou le PDG de la 5 lui a répondu sur
TF1 les dirigeants de cette chaîne ou de
chaîne
future doivent principalement fonder
leur programmation sur sur la création
française et faire confiance aux
créateurs français c'est pourquoi je
souhaite de toutes mes forces
que les clauses même du cahier de
concession
soi révisé de manière à faire confiance
d'abord au créateurs français moi je dis
on va rien démolir du tout le cinéma
français est un cinéma qui est le plus
fort d'Europe c'est le deuxè du monde et
nous comptons tout à fait collaborer
avec lui mais aujourd'hui
tous les films récents de qualité sont
déjà vendus aux chaînes donc il nous
faut un certain temps pour pouvoir à la
fois faire des coproductions avec le
cinéma et en même temps pour voir
trouver des films de qualité que les
Français
souhaitent